uno spazio
partecipa
vai al video
la libertà la nostra società delle
regole e chi non rispetta quelle regole
paga con la perdita della libertà ma
quando l'individuo esce e la pena
termina si misura la sua utilità e
l'utilità dell'istituzione carceraria
per questo lavorare in carcere è molto
importante se un individuo ha acquisito
frustrazione e risentimento sarà pronto
a delinquere di nuovo se invece avrà
acquisito a conoscenza ed esperienza
allora potrà costruire un nuovo percorso
personale in italia esistono 53 mila
detenuti
più o meno come tutta la popolazione di
siena o se volete metà di quella di
vicenza ma per questi 53 mila carcerati
esistono 49 mila posti e questo è un
dato in netto miglioramento
frutto di battaglie leggi speciali e ben
tre condanne consecutive del tribunale
di strasburgo per i diritti dell'uomo al
governo italiano per tortura e
trattamenti inumani
infatti solo tre anni fa in italia
c'erano 67mila detenuti a fronte di
45.000 posti di capienza stimata e per
capienza stimata indichiamo in realtà un
dato diverso perché è la tollerabilità
massima dei carceri ovvero circa il
doppio della recettività a progetto
questo significa che in una stanza una
cella pensata per una persona di circa
2,7 per 3,5 metri sono nove metri quadri
a persona
in realtà vivono fino a scusate vivono
fino a tre detenuti con tre metri quadri
testa letto incluso vivere in tre metri
quadri significa respirare l'aria di un
altro non avere accesso al bagno non
riuscire a camminare non riuscire a
mantenersi lucidi e puliti e in un
carcere sovraffollato così il letto
diventa il vero luogo di reclusione
perché la direzione spesso sceglie per
evitare problemi di sicurezza di
limitare le ore d'aria in questo modo i
primi a risentirne sono i programmi di
riabilitazione e lo stato così
predispone paradossalmente a nuovi
crimini quei cittadini che vivono la
straordinaria condizione di essere
completamente sotto la sua
responsabilità a spoleto c'è uno dei
carceri di massima sicurezza italiani
lì c'è una falegnameria che produce gran
parte degli arredi per gli altri carceri
italiani questa storia iniziali marco
tortoioli ricci con il suo studio di
grafica e comunicazione conduce a
spoleto dei corsi professionalizzanti
grafica e tipografia per i detenuti
marco è il primo autore di questa storia
al di qua delle sbarre insieme ad aldo
cibic e al sottoscritto
l'idea di marco è semplice perché non
organizzare un incontro per raccontare
il design a quei detenuti che stanno
imparando a diventare falegnami fernando
massimo vincenzo ben ali e leo ci
aspettavano intorno a un tavolo
loro erano stati selezionati per
imparare a fare il falegname da
quell'incontro ci aspettavamo una
maggiore presa di coscienza di quello
che può essere il progetto o forse
qualche arredo più strano che sarebbe
potuto essere esposta una mostra o forse
e rivenduto per arrotondare i bilanci
delle iniziative del carcere non
sapevamo che la lezione l'avremo
ricevuto a noi inizia vincenzo lui
era un designer un designer di barche
30.000 stuzzicadenti
ci vogliono per realizzare una barca in
cella incollati uno a uno
dopo avergli tagliato le punte era
iniziata così una gara per raccontare le
esperienze più straordinarie e
incredibili che avvengono in quel mondo
del limite dove la creatività si
sprigiona scoprimmo così che in carcere
un letto può diventare una scarpiera il
bagno diventa la cucina uno sgabello in
dotazione può diventare un forno con cui
cucinare una crostata in carcere tutto
diventa un oggetto che è una seconda
vita è il regno del riciclo perché la
cella a pochissimi elementi per ragioni
di sicurezza un letto un tavolo una
sedia pochissimo fummo molto colpiti da
questa energia creativa che rilegge e
reinventa uno spazio pensato per
dividere e decidemmo di utilizzarla per
fare un progetto insieme
è così che è nata freedom room vincenzo
ben ali leo fernando divennero così da
studenti a nostri consulenti e pensammo
un modulo abitativo pensato per hotel a
basso costo ospitalità diffusa campus o
studentati un oggetto che doveva essere
realizzato con tecnologie semplici
perché era stato pensato e doveva essere
costruito in carcere ma anche con
materiali poveri per mantenere bassi i
costi facendo così tesoro delle
esperienze quotidiani dei carcerati e
freedom room è un modulo e
principalmente realizzato in legno legno
di abete che è molto semplice da
lavorare
e facile da assemblare l'esperienza dei
carcerati ci hanno permesso di pensare
un design neutro che accoglie le azioni
invece che definirle e così c'è spazio
per tutto i letti non sono più
sovrapposti per evitare un ordine una
precedenza dei posti più preziosi o meno
inferiori e il modulo dei letti che
possono anche essere dei divani
leggere o rilassarsi il bagno un locale
tecnico dove le mensole possono
asciugare e ci si può cucinare o lavare
il piano e multifunzione con una piccola
zona dove si può tagliare per fare altre
cose
e c'è uno spazio dove mettere tutte le
proprie cose per appropriarsi dello
spazio e una grande apertura permette
alla luce naturale di entrare e perché
no di avere un orto in terrazzo freedon
room è un modulo dalle dimensioni
compatte una proposta modulare ad alta
dignità aggiunta bello con poco
un modulo che può vivere da solo per
progetti diffusi o magari aggregato per
ospitalità più strutturate essere
posizionato all'esterno o magari
all'interno per rivalutare ripensare
edifici che oggi non hanno più una
funzione
pensate a cosa succede in tutti gli
aeroporti del mondo con i cap sull'hotel
è un prodotto pensato per il mercato
realizzato in carcere un simbolo un
oggetto che permette la riabilitazione
ma anche un timido suggerimento per
ripensare quello che è la vita nel
carcere oggi è un esempio di quelli che
possono essere i nuovi ruoli tra design
da una parte e pubblico dall'altra per
una porosità tra privato e stato che
permetta di superare quei problemi a cui
l'economia di oggi non riesce più a dare
delle risposte
per questo motivo lo abbiamo chiamato
freedom room